on soit ravel black-out merci d'être
avec nous en direct sur rt france alors
après jean yves le drian juillet dernier
c'est la deuxième visite officielle d'un
ministre français dans la capitale
irakienne ce déplacement de florence
parly est il synonyme d'un renforcement
des relations entre la france et l'irak
on peut le lire comme ça
il cotait depuis le désengagement des
états unis d'amérique en irak
la france est la première puissance
internationale qui saurait engage
massivement on y laisse au réengagement
de la france ce n'est pas uniquement si
tu rien il ya la foi et culturels
scientifiques et économiques
sécuritaires militaires et diplomatiques
la france oui on peut dire totalement
engagés sur le front irakien
ça veut dire que justement le départ des
états unis laisse un vide qu'il faut
combler et paris aimerait justement être
présent davantage aux 1900 fin
pardonnez-moi en 2011 lorsque barack
obama à retirer ses troupes de l'irak
il y avait un vide invite politique un
vide sécuritaire un vide était clos
matic un vide économique sur vidas était
un rapidement rempli par la république
islamique nous dirons alors leurs
résultats aujourd'hui malheureusement
c'est le système international gpi du
système international paye très cher
même les états unis d'amérique à un pays
très très cher saône
cette présence massive de la république
islamique et doullens depuis 2011
aujourd'hui lorsque les états unis
d'amérique se retirent d'irak et se
retire à la fois diplomatiquement a
politiquement économiquement sécurité
offert à toutes les échelles darel à la
france la république française ne
souhaite absolument pas laisser la main
à d'autres acteurs nos désirable
de dominer la scène gilles ratia nous et
la france en tant que puissance
internationale souhaite fortement sous
prose se présenter comme une alternative
alors la france 5 et 1 6 et sur la lutte
contre l' état islamique en soutien avec
l'irak
est-ce que clairement notre pays a les
moyens de lutter contre lui pas écouté
la france à 2 2 c'est très très
important de dos c'est très urgent à
traiter avec les partenaires irakiens
le premier dossier bien évidemment vous
l'avez dit c'est le retour en force de
l'organisation d' états islamiques son
retour en force militaire j'ai des biens
militaires de l'état islamique menace
non seulement l'état irakien mais aussi
les pays du système régional mais aussi
des pays du système international dont
la france est le deuxième dossier c'est
là nos fonds cible turque dans le nord
direct dans le kurdistan irakien
sa guerre contre l'organisation du pkk
qui en inquiète fortement la france et
la diplomatie française la france a
traité a abordé les dossiers avec perdez
et bagdad
est ce que la france a les moyens pour
être une alternative crédible des états
unis d'amérique
la question n'est pas évidente
est ce que la france a la volonté oui la
france à elle seule ne peut pas être une
alternative la france avec les pays
européens oui tout à fait en mesure
objectivement mesure ils sont en mesure
les pays européens de remplir ce vide
aujourd'hui pour qu'on se rende compte
concrètement la situation quelles sont
les forces de l'état islamique en irak
la force majeure de l'état islamique et
c'est la base militante la base sociale
sunnite
la communauté sunnite
elle même à les abandonner elle et elle
est marginalisée elle est pas intégrée
elle est exclue vous savez de la guerre
de d'agir contre l'organisation de
l'état islamique de 2014 à 2017 a
détruit à cause de cette guerre à la
halle au pays des sunnites totalement
détruit les villes les villages
aujourd'hui vous rendez encore à mossoul
vous trouvez des cadavres au centre de
montceau là autrement dit la
reconstruction n'est pas n'a pas comme
n'a pas démarré les services publics
totalement absent une domaine
une domination sauvage des pardonnez moi
pour l'expression des à des milices
chiites dans le territoire sous need
ddd des massacres collective on parle
certains parlent certains chercheurs et
observateurs parlent même d'un génocide
sous need de la part des milices chiites
alors tant que cette question sous need
n'est pas réglée au sein du système
politique irakien daraîche bien
évidemment trouvera sa base militante et
à sa base sociale solidement enracinée
dans ma société irakienne merci beaucoup
avait là-bas kahone d'avoir été avec
nous en direct sur arte france